grosse nouveauté sur votre iPhone vous
pouvez dès à présent venir personnaliser
votre écran d'accueil différemment de
votre écran de verrouillage vous venez
ici dans vos réglages dans vos réglages
vous allez sur fond d'écran et fond
d'écran vous voyez ici vous pouvez venir
les moduler indépendamment l'un de
l'autre quel que soit votre thème quel
que soit vos fonds d'écran c'est très
très facile vous personnaliser l'écran
d'accueil très facilement de différentes
manières et vous voulez qu'un effet
différent ici vous cliquez sur
personnalisé et vous voulez par exemple
une couleur qui va pas être la même vous
pouvez mettre un petit dégradé ou même
carrément venir mettre une photo donc
d'un côté je vais avoir ça d'un côté
genre ma photo je trouve ça pratique on
peut vraiment aller beaucoup plus loin
dans la personnalisation qui était quand
même plutôt rare c'est intéressant
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire et pour plus d'astuces
d'infos pensez à vous abonner